[Musique]
parce que tu dis que tu
veux parce que tu dis que tu crois parce
que tu crois que tu me veux et puis que
ça
durera parce que nos amours un jour
seront lassés de vivre au jour le
jour chaque jour que Dieu fait il
fallait que tu saches
que tu as pris la
place d'un amour qui se cache au crô mes
souvenirs son visage me hentete me
poursuit nuit et jours je sais pas ce
qui te manque pour être cet amour
voilà pourquoi tu
peux faire ce que bon te
semble faire ce que bon te semble
ble tu me
rends quand même
heureux parce que tu lui
ressembles tu lui
ressembles pourtant si tu
savais combien je l'ai
aimé souvent tu
oublierais de te faire
pardonner et lorsqu'au petit jour tu
rentres au bras d'un autre ne m plus
cher
amour pour me cacher ta faute c'esttu
que c'est
matin il m'arrive
parfois de croire qu'elle
revient lorsque j'entends ton
pas je me colle à la porte et puis ce
n'est que toi alors mes amours morte
Meur encore une fois
voilà pourquoi tu
peux faire ce que bon te semble faire ce
que bon te
semble tu me
rends quand même
heureux parce que tu lui
ressembles tu lui
ressembles il est trop tard maintenant
pour tout
recommencer on na plus guère le temps
d'oublier le passé
demain nous serons vieux que va-t-il
nous rester tu m'aimes un tout petit peu
et tu te crois aimer
voilà pourquoi tu peux faire ce que bon
te semble faire ce que bon te
semble tu me
rends quand même
heureux parce que tu lui ressembles
tu lui
ressembles parce que tu lui
ressembles tu lui
ressembles et quelle était ma
vie